us about those trees now they didn't
hear it but I like for them to hear you
talked about true so amazed yeah let me
get let me get the book out scientists
always use a language which normally
couldn't be understood and so I
translated this and surprise surprise
trees Alvin means trees social trees
have feelings and we often hear the
problem how many verses in Panem about
water many many many Sahaba registration
and the juma Salah the professionalism
ascends to the pulpit and the Sahaba
they're there so that every Sahabi
explains this narration in his own words
so the worldís alarm ascends the pulpit
and when the essence appalled by the
Sahaba said that we heard a crying from
the date palm tree some of them say that
it was as though he was shaking like it
was going to explode others say it was
like a she-camel whose child had been
snatched away as I said that it was like
a she-camel who's screaming once it
giving birth
others say it was like a little baby
whose mother had been taken away from it
can you imagine a date palm tree and
then the prophets Alhassan descended
from the pulpit and he embraced it he
embraced the date palm tree until the
sobbing slowly stopped and the progress
Allison gave it an option of being a
tree in Jena from which the awliya and
Ursula ha and the MBR the pious people
will eat from its fruits and it chose to
be a tree in Jenna and her son bacilli
Rehema holidays if this is the love that
the tree had for the morris Allah
illallah wa sallam
then what is the love that believers
should have for the prophets of Allah
leave us alone now Hamza he brought up
something amazing
regarding some science regarding trees
the book is called the hidden life of
trees it was a UH it was an
international bestseller and it's called
what they feel how they communicate
discoveries from a secret world right it
sounds like a fiction book right but
it's actually nonfiction so from I
remember and read the book free so so
you get this understanding is that trees
communicate with each other they even
have a form of altruism where they help
each other they hope give certain
species of their own species more
nutrients right they understand which
tree belongs to their species right also
if some animals eating for a particular
leaf that tree was sent I think a gas
signal to the other trees to warn them
animals are coming when they get that
gas signal it the base the trees
basically produce this bitter resin or
something and when Anna was try and eat
it big its bitter so this book is so
amazing it just showed me like Wow
trees are living organisms and you know
what I'm not a beach person I'm a forest
person you know sometimes say to the
kids Beach or forest while say to people
beach or forest sometimes people choose
Beach sometimes I'm over forest you know
why because when I walk into a first bro
it's almost like a mystical experience
like you're in an organism you're in a
live thing that's talking that's
breathing you know the hidys about the
tree that cried yeah Allahu Akbar
trees talk to each other you know one
would even argue that trees feel pain
right they send signals to each other
they communicate they understand which
tree belongs to their species
they have altruism from what I remember
double check this out for yourself in
the book trees sacrifice themselves for
other tree's right that is phenomenal
and amazing yeah so from this point of
view you know there's so much more we
can learn about reality and this should
increase your image bingo check this off
this is a yeah yeah absolutely
he's written a very accessible way but
it's all based on
consenting trees thank you for sharing
yeah absolutely